es tía para kate miriam gómez y su madre
sunilda repasan la historia familiar en
camino a visitarlos a patricia gómez
mientras es humilde y sobrina de miriam
en quien ella se ve reflejada una
importante referente de la comunidad
afro aquí en argentina obviamente de la
comunidad caboverdiana también en
argentina según datos oficiales hacia
2010 había unos 150.000
afrodescendientes pero una investigación
académica estimó que podían ser
alrededor de 2 millones un país en el
que el racismo está acompañado de la
invisibilización por mestizaje y por
negación yo creo que es igualmente
racista por un factor que es el de la
invisibilización que no se dio en otros
países creo que el concepto de
blanqueamiento que se dio en toda
latinoamérica en argentina triunfó
ampliamente y en otros países fue mucho
más dificultoso sunilda reconoce que fue
con las nuevas generaciones que entendió
el racismo tomar conciencia de que hay
racismo sí sí a partir de ella me voy
dando cuenta que
que existe dios dejes una revolución
silenciosa porque ella permitió criar
mujeres no que han sido libres sobre
todo a miriam que es la única mujer de
cinco hermanos rodeada de varones una
mujer libre que pudo estudiar también a
nietas que también hoy pudimos ir a la
universidad así las tres generaciones se
reconocen parte de una continuidad en la
lucha por los derechos de las mujeres
afro argentinas que siguen llevando
adelante